at a secret location in western ukraine
these ukrainian civilians are receiving
a specialized training course
they're learning to fight like
wolverines
this is something new and special i've
never been part of anything like this
before
last month after russian forces suffered
a crushing defeat near ukraine's capital
residents surveying the damage came
across a peculiar site abandoned russian
military vehicles spray painted with the
word wolverines the photos shared on
social media sparked international
intrigue over who was responsible
well now the secretive group is stepping
out of the shadows for the first time
granting global news exclusive access
inside their operation
[Applause]
we're going in loud and we're going in
fast
the wolverines are led by around 100
volunteers from 20 countries american
british and canadian combat veterans and
former special forces
here to fight the russians and train the
ukrainians because a lot of these guys
don't have any training this wolverine's
instructor is from bc the more people we
can train that's more people who can
help defend the country so we can do a
lot more by
training the guys here than just going
to the front
over three months they provided this
week-long crash course to more than six
thousand ukrainians from soldiers to
civilians
a lot literally a lot from the guys this
ukrainian one of the first to be trained
had no combat experience now he's
training others
how it was three months ago how i am now
is completely different level
besides learning how to clear an
abandoned building perform rescues and
operate an ak-47
the wolverines are also learning the
power
of a symbol
the wolverines shoulder patch is
inspired by a cold war classic
the fictional 1984 film red dawn about a
group of american teens who fight off a
soviet invasion of the united states all
while using their high school mascot's
name as a calling card before completing
their training the ukrainians are
required to watch the movie for
inspiration
and the guys absolutely love it it's a
clear
presentation
of how
young motivated people
not professional soldiers can step up
step up to the plate
and knock it out of the park the
wolverines and their ukrainian students
then head together to the front lines
armed with guns and cans of spray paint
to leave their mark
it's
something to inspire people people see
it
they know we're here they know that
they're not alone and it seems that
message is getting through
[Music]
a ukrainian pop star just released this
music video dedicated to the wolverines
meanwhile in central ukraine they took
down this soviet statue and replaced it
with the wolverines tagged tank
this was like a beacon of hope for our
guys it really was that the people are
getting it they see it they're out there
they love it but also this has an impact
on the psychology of the russians you
know to know that the world has united
against them we're here
and he says they're here to stay until
the war
is won
jeff semple global news in western
ukraine